okay community member can come back and
uh
not hope not
right
right exactly
all right so let's uh let's let's just
have a general uh conversation here
about
what were some of the Impressions that
you heard this morning and then it's my
intent
to be out of here by 12 30 all right
okay we need to warm up
but anyway
uh any any general comments uh
any Impressions that you had this
morning that uh
yeah okay yes
yeah I would say we don't have enough
Staffing for anything
so how do you how do you fix that
problem other than you know student loan
forgiveness or whatever for these jobs
and I don't even know if that would help
any but you know the
they're going out of state
so how do you
yeah as I find it interesting Kareem
when you mentioned the um you know the
one-on-one eighth we keep getting more
one-on-one A's but these kids some of
these kids it's it's you're just trying
to put a stopper on what they're doing
and are you really educating them so
that's just myself what do you do about
it it's in dry
thanks um working on that we when we
were talking about the nursing school
nurses and being able to do it before
you finish with your degree for example
so I would be interested in looking at
those rules of who does who which came
you know where that has a basis in law
what of who does tests for what and see
if we can do some a similar situation
okay
representative
well I kind of go back to um the
training as as well that you know unless
you have trained people that are
specifically trained and and as she said
professional Educators dealing with
these problems
you know I I would hate because we have
a staffing issue to to water it down you
know as far as that's concerned and I
think we also need to look at What
legislation we're passing that that
makes things easier and better for
people and What legislation have we
passed or that we have been talking
about that actually
diminishes the the ability of the
schools to do to to reach kids that are
having mental health problems or to deal
with kids that just have social
emotional problems on a daily level
um
at one point somewhere in school psych
or whatever they often talked about how
teenage years are a mental condition in
itself you know so uh you know it's
every day uh when you're teaching you
have these little things bubbling up in
your classroom or kids coming in or if
you're coaching you know oftentimes you
get kids coming and talking to you and
considering that the climate right now
and some of the legislation we've passed
I feel as a classroom teacher I would be
very hesitant to to do or to talk about
certain things and and it would it
restricts your ability to interact with
kids
representative Damon
Echo everything that's been said but
also or and also
it's between mental health education
for the entire student population
I believe is a very very different
opportunity
than much of our discussion today about
how are we addressing the needs of
students who have a mental health
condition
yeah and I think it's important when we
talk about 505
and the whole bundle
that we are careful to separate
how and what might we be educating
so that people have a better
understanding of Mental Health
which isn't treatment
it's not therapy
the Educators do need appropriate
knowledge and training for sure
but it's not anywhere near the level of
training of a professional who would
treat a mental health condition
not all mental health conditions can be
prevented
but many are less likely to occur if
people know the risk factors and know
the lifestyles and behaviors that reduce
risk
yeah that that that was a con that was
an aha moment for me too I mean the
whole issue of the curriculum of
Education vis-a-vis what's the
intervention service
right and that's and that's one of the
places where you get into the whole
Staffing issue of what's available I
mean I mean when you hear somebody it's
got to wait two years to get a damn
referral to Services I mean that's I
don't know I'm sorry sorry I spoke a
little bit but I I got I got wood
all right and I'm sorry no no just jump
jumping on to Pope and Mel's comment
right there you know I'm sort of seeing
it as as really three things though
there's the um there's the water factors
that contribute to it
how do you go about treating it and how
you go about identifying
um it so so so you know I think the
point Linda made was really getting at
the what are the factors that contribute
um to this epidemic and is this
partially an epidemic of our making
and um
you know can I answer that you cut in
for just a second on that I was reading
a report that came out in 2003 regarding
Civics education in our schools
here's here's the statement many
teachers fear criticism or even
litigation if they address topics that
may be considered controversial or
political in nature
so what we're experiencing today is not
uncommon from what was experienced 20
years ago
and and so I I think that we we have to
get away from that a little bit and be
able to get into the ability that we're
going to be discussing and talking about
these topics and mental health is one of
them and we've got to resolve it and we
have to have those intervention
resources available and it's it's
handled differently and I honestly
believe a lot of it is based on
resources in the community but also
leadership in the buildings
if you don't have proper leadership in a
building with all the money in the world
you're not going to get things fixed
and and I can recall as a principal I
invited Community Mental Health to come
in and be in my building I've provided
them a room two or three days a week
depending upon where we got with that
need we were a school of about 500 kids
and I had all the resources there but I
was lacking the resource of community
involvement and and you know it's acting
like that Silo I sometimes talk about
and with that within three or four years
of bringing Community Mental Health into
the building
our issues in the building just just
lessened it was just a wonderful
environment and it wasn't coming from a
prejudiced principle here it was just
very observable by community and parents
all together but that resource has to be
available
that's what we were talking about today
when you were a tier chair lab that even
if schools want to bring in the mental
health professionals there's such a
shortage right now in in every area that
that you know there can't be wrapper on
Services because there just isn't
anything available and that money dries
up and the state doesn't assume that
burden and that's what's happened here
and it's happening right now when we're
losing the Gopher money and everything
else yeah and do you remember when they
closed the state hospital 30 years ago
and they funded the Community Mental
Health Centers how well they were funded
and all the services they could provide
and they aren't funded at all now it's
really cut down and one of the things we
talked about too is whether Jane can
find out some State models that we might
want to look at
uh vis-a-vis what we currently have here
that might be a at least a platform for
us to begin to look at what some of the
components might be easiest yeah that's
true ECS might be able to have the same
uh yes representative education
Commission in the states and Jennifer
for is listening this it's being
streamed and she's going to review this
whole thing and she is a researcher
that's available to us good
yeah I'm wondering
schools still have to be schools and
they still have to teach and teachers
are trained to teach but they're not
trained to be psychologists
and
what we know from social emotional
learning is if it's going to be
effective it needs to be in the school
at the home
and in the community and they all have
to work together and it seems like part
of our we have a couple of breakdowns
one is in the community what do we do
about that I mean here we are we're
education right and it seems like we're
trying to solve an education
a fundamental underlying issue with
community
and even when you get as they were
saying even when you get referrals
to outside sources the parents don't get
them there and so there's
that whole breakdown and how are we as
educators
dealing with or can we even deal with
the overall cultural breakdown
um there is not just in our state but
all over an extreme shortage of
trained people healthcare workers and so
even as they were saying how can you get
somebody like that in the school when
you can't even get them out of the
school and part of that
as I'm discovering through my husband
who's on Edna is all the requirements on
licensing and all of that kind of stuff
with psychologists in this state
they're finding that and we've talked to
some
that it was a totally subjected somebody
could have we talked to a man who went
through all of the school stuff passed
all of the things passed all of his
exams and everything and then they had a
how do you feel about this and they
wouldn't give him the license
because they had an agenda they had a
political whatever and he didn't fit
that
and that's I mean that's not an
education thing but it is happening in
our state and we talked to this guy who
now is looking for a completely
different type of job
just
because whatever reason so that's being
done in Edna and they're trying to look
at licensing and trying to clear that up
so that may help with some of our supply
but um I know it's a crazy thing that
that something should be subjective
instead of objective as to whether or
not you get a license well one of the
things too that Melissa talked about was
the issue of the agencies working
together and I I re I can vividly
remember the conversation we had in this
group when we were talking about
Medicaid expansion
and yet he had the the HHS over here in
the department or the education
department over here and said okay well
well how are you talking to one another
and I would think that that goes back to
the whole question of how do you get
these multiple agencies to provide the
kinds of foundational support that's
there regardless of where you are but at
least you need to be talking with one
another uh represent woodcock
thanks chairman I want to go back to a
couple of points when you started the
discussion what do we think from the
from the earlier meeting
um I think Linda was hitting on uh
representative Tana not necessarily the
the CRT
propola but rather the the linking of
administrative rules and teachers losing
time in the classroom especially I teach
a losing time in a classroom for the
amount of regulatory things we put in
across the state or doe puts in that
takes the time to get away from teaching
but the bigger piece of this to me is
the fact that it's clear uh to me anyhow
and as is I'm sure on this table that we
have a youth Mental Health crisis in New
Hampshire and we have the United States
but right now our focus is on New
Hampshire and the model that we're using
the delay referral test waiting list all
that time those youngsters aren't
getting the adequate education they
should be getting I don't know finding a
lot of time in real life with with
teachers and staff and I I disagree with
Alicia and I think that we need the
school unfortunately is put in the
position that they have to take on more
of a task as we have kids who need food
we have to feed them some of us think we
have to feed them as we need if the kids
who needs mental health you have to
provide that because we take any Pieces
away the educational success of the
youngsters is not going to matriculate
so I'm thinking that we really need to
look at you know it's not the name broke
don't break you know don't fix it I
think it broke
I think the way we look at mental health
and education here under our auspices
under the legislative hospitals under
the doe auspice it broke and this is
just one piece of that and and we can't
wait five or six or seven years to say
how we're gonna go back and fix this
these kids that live now I got five
seven years forget the testing results
they're going to be folks out of the
school who don't have skills
and I think that's what we can't we
can't keep on delaying I think what came
to me today is listened to all three and
we have three different presentations
here coming from three different
perspectives and they all basically said
the same thing we got prices
and and the traditional way of fixing
things just can't be doing that so I
that's what you asked when you started
the dialogue grows in Milo what did you
get out of the meeting that's what I got
we we have to step up and do something
uh and not put it in the slow mode until
like five years waiting I get thank you
yeah uh representative McDonald I think
you're representative Miler and yes this
is important and the first presentation
was from UNH extension and on the
handout they gave they have survey data
from the youth risk behavior survey
these data points that say concerning
information about students attempting
suicide and mental health risks we've
had previous discussions about this
survey and have determined that at best
it might be inaccurate and
the department has testified today that
at the very best that's your own
segmentation is back dated two years so
my question is because this is so
important what can we do to get more
accurate surveys because since resources
are so limited we need to unfortunately
Target these resources to those who need
it most and how can we tell that if the
survey date is a little bit at least
backdated two years so my question is
what can we do to improve this survey
data
enough
thank you very much Mr chair
um you you had mentioned about the the
silos and I'm wondering if we're sort of
jumping into one here as well because I
think the area that we're talking about
certainly extends far beyond the typical
policy areas of this committee and um
and when you were talking about it
earlier Mel it made me it made me think
about
some of the policy areas that the HHS
committee gets involved with and some of
the policy areas the Commerce Committee
uh gets involved with particularly when
it comes to mental health parity policy
um uh you know with respect to different
Insurance programs and uh we're
certainly I think our our two-hour you
know two hours worth of of meeting this
morning certainly the words funding came
up a number of times and uh and Paul's
possibly uh funding mechanisms for for
for this sort of
um uh you know for mental health uh
could come from outside of the um
the the typical adequate education funds
and uh when we take a look at the
numbers and we can disagree on on
the numbers but uh but I think it's
certainly affecting a substantial number
of students and um and the result of
that effect is not inconsequential on
those that the students learning and and
their success in life and and our
economy and everything else that um that
that contributes to that but but
possibly Mr chair uh we may want to
convene a um uh maybe a a work group
that that includes some folks from from
HHS and folks from Commerce and um and I
was particularly looking up um maybe
maybe you know like John dejoy who would
spend quite a bit of time in Commerce
and um and has I think he also
represents the um the mental health
counseling I think Jane
um
and and you know that that certainly
something that that we're talking about
is maybe being a resource yeah you're
suggesting that we have our Silo here
yeah that's what I'm suggesting is that
is that where siled so here's here's
what I here's what I have I just
this is not a definitive list but
I've got what we've talked about in the
last 20 minutes we've got the issue of
staffing issues
training of Educators around this issue
the impact of legislation both
negatively and positively around
schools and services Etc
we talked a little bit about the
differentiation of health education
versus services and intervention issues
which are separate
and we talked a little bit about State
models and then the issue we just talked
about perhaps the need
to have some joint committee work on
this and I think also the issue that
representative McDonald mentioned too
are there other are there other metrics
that we can look at too that would go
beyond just the the other one survey I
mean we need to see what are the issues
out there where we've got some metrics
around this and not just the one survey
that we've talked about here within this
committee so those I think Mr chair
those are the issues that I think that
we've we've been talking about in your
absence those are good and I I'd like to
just Echo what I heard yesterday from
several teachers which were testifying
or was was yesterday or day before
teacher is being spit on right now
uh things have changed since covid kids
you know for example even the two high
school boys I put on the plane last
night to try to get to
Myrtle Beach got down to DC and had to
do a little bit of time there because
the storms and all
um they one had the experience of being
in school during covid
one day a week
the other student because he was in a
lower grade
and was there for four days a week guess
who has the good study habits right now
guess the one that's on task and the one
that is still very compliant and and and
knows what rules mean the one that was
there four days per week it was the one
that wasn't was pretty much on his own
doing his own thing and now we have kids
walking in the door in the schoolhouse
with some of them with that type of
mentality right now and it's been very
very difficult in fact I have a daughter
who is a special ed teacher dealing with
life skills and she was pushed down the
stairwell and had to have her hip
replaced
by as by a kid that was just emotionally
disturbed
and and so this is but that's not
necessarily uncommon today we have
teachers being hurt and we have other
kids being hurt we have deaths being
thrown around and it's pretty sad when
you have to evacuate a classroom saying
all the kids are doing a good job get
out of here and we'll take care of the
one that's not that's kind of you know a
reverse psychology than what I've been
used to as an administrator or a teacher
so there's a lot we have to do here but
the data we're using I'd like to make
sure we're using solid data I'd like to
make sure that
um there there are schools where maybe
they're not having the degree of of
issue my question would be what's so
different about that school then what's
the best practice that they're doing
there
and so we oftentimes look at figures and
we say well this percentage is apropos
for the whole state well maybe maybe not
I know that when I talk to a senator
dalessandro he was saying well we have
you know uh folks in every one of our
schools now that is a community resource
type person because of the Dynamics of
the the the the student that's coming to
them and and so
what's good happening in Manchester may
not be happening in Hopkinton
maybe I don't know so I'd like to make
sure the data is accurate and that's the
unfortunate thing I I don't think we've
ever really gotten good data
um I know that you know I've asked for
data before from doe you know on on
costs of things and they've been like
three four million dollars off
and that was not uncommon six or seven
years ago
and and and so the it's whether they
don't have the Personnel or they they
don't the accountability is something
which we're lacking the knowledge of
what's going on the schools and somehow
the survey work we gotta we can't be
satisfied with a 20 return or a 30
return you get those from those that are
compliant returning but I'd like to see
something we talked about the health
survey they get back every biennium
when you get a hold of that and I'll
make sure everybody gets copy you'd be
very appalled to see what's on it
there are some that just say no I'm not
teaching PE
um um
I'm wondering if the regional Public
Health Centers might be able to
um be a part of coordination because
when you're talking about agencies
sometimes it can be done in regions so
that they're coordinated that's one
thought school districts who have
healthier financial budget also higher
full-time social workers in their
districts
poor districts can't get that that's
that's a key parent School connector the
third piece to think about is a lot of
schools have done the response to
intervention model or the multi-tiered
systems of behavior the PBIS is also
another model or responsive classroom at
the elementary school as a model but
data collection is key for all of that
and if you have a social emotional
learning program
you have to collect social emotional
data
and so I question I mean we issued a
screening to young kids
to make sure they were okay you know
it's a check-in type process
um
but the legislation on non-academic
surveys now May
curtail that I mean is that in conflict
I didn't I don't know
Maybe
and adding to that do we know what
keen's doing what Plymouth State's doing
what UNH is doing in terms of preparing
these folks they're coming up to the
elementary schools coming out of a
program what type of skills are they
being taught
do we need that data
I would say we do we need to do some
looking into that
I don't know if the middle still running
this or not but Alicia
on that note my question
um
yes we have rules about student filled
out data
but what there's a lot of data we should
be able to have about how many behavior
issues a school has what they're seeing
in particular I mean that's teacher and
administrator filled out as opposed to
because there are no rules about what
they can now teachers say I'm supposed
to be teaching I've heard this a number
of times and not
filling out surveys
and not keeping track of numbers of
incidences and stuff like that but it
seems like
can we somehow look at the evidences of
disturbance as opposed to trying to just
do a student survey
the teacher shortage committee has
requested that we have some principles
come in uh it was brought up just the
other day when we're talking about this
very issue that a teacher would notice
that there's a problem in the classroom
and it's a disruptive problem so the kid
is sent out four minutes later the kid's
back in the classroom after being down
the principal's office and it hasn't
been resolved but you have to deal with
it so that's that's not uncommon so how
do we capture that information
and that that's why I said very
beginning of this thing leadership in
the building is imperative and you have
to have rules within a building and we
can't get away from that and
unfortunately a lot of them coming out
of covid they don't know what rules are
and the parameters are now wider and
then they were pre-coveted
and and that's part of what I believe
we're we're encountering
not all of it but part of it
and I was wondering whether or not the
disciplinary records might be in data of
use to it because if people are acting
out there's some causality in there we
we don't know what it is but it's there
and the department collects that
information yeah
yeah it's aggregated though
represent Damon
thank you
I have great respect for the need for
data and for
confirming that whatever is being done
is effective
and I am also
really feeling like we already have so
much data that tells us how much of a
crisis we have
and we really need to be looking at what
are we doing to address the crisis
more than getting more data
I'm not saying we shouldn't also get
data
but I'm hearing an awful lot of
conversation about surveys survey that
we have day of this data that
what are we going to do to address the
problem
not just Define it further
yeah I was just saying that would be
that would be part of the data it's not
what are the things but what is done
what is effective what is not effective
that would be part of what
well that's true but we're doing
something and so is it effective is it
not effective is this school doing
something that is effective and this
school doing what is not effective and
can we look at that and then say this
might be a better effective a more
effective solution
representative
thank you
um I would think there's three parts the
mental health intervention the crisis
part we've heard about today the pot we
started on today with the mental health
education and the curriculum that goes
to the background of the other things
the third particularly you spoke about
is the leadership in the school uh and
the and what the youngster going back
and discipline all those things and that
leadership is critical but I think what
we've forgotten in that
peace is the parental support for the
leadership in the school and if you
don't have parental support for the
leadership in the school then the least
of the school starts to diminish and and
shrivel up uh and is not effective ears
you are an effective administrator and I
think that's that's like the other
hanging chat out there
foreign
I guess too that's where the the
communication between the teacher and
the home but also the administrator has
to be a supportive of the staff within
that building and and if you're not
um then then it's going to go downhill
real fast
uh I I can remember in a building that I
had that I came in I think I mentioned
this before where I collected all the
report cards and found out the average
grade and the school was like a minus in
a huge School
I said well I didn't know our kids were
geniuses and then I went back to the
teachers and they said well you know the
parents are looking for oh wait and I
said this a c is a c that's average
they're doing a pretty good job to get
that but what happens when they come in
and complain I said send them to me
and that's where the principal has to
stand up and say this is the expectation
of this school and that's the difference
between schools which are Schools of
Excellence and those schools which are
just okay
and and I've I'm a firm believer that
leadership and staff have to work
together and but leadership has to be
there saying yeah this is a yes or this
is a no and and and
I guess I got my point across there
representative Tanner did you see the
two plus two video
Rick no just make sure you get a copy of
it so I agree with representative
Woodcock that that we've got
um three at least three distinct areas
but I think one of the ones that we can
focus on and try to really
um make a difference right away is
school climate and and the school
climate being you know the healthy
habits of well-being uh number one good
leadership that that understands how
important that is food every kid's not
hungry
um and having uh you know some of the
again going back to some of the
legislation legislative
decisions we've made uh that have been
put into law that really restrict uh
having a healthy climate in a school
being able to have a healthy climate in
the school but I think that's that's one
part that's not therapy okay that and
you've got to divide that up teachers
don't do therapy okay they but uh they
do as much social emotional uh help and
setting these areas for well-being and
trying to make the climate the best for
the child to learn and the best for the
child to grow and
um that shouldn't be restricted
represent Ford
I think one of the things that we're
stepping around without saying
is that a lot of the decisions that
affect this are made in the communities
in the way they're willing to fund the
schools
and I have read School assignments where
you have certain number of special ed
kids and they're all supposed to have
individualized education or
help
and they're clustered together in one
room under a teacher with a right
certification but they're taught as a
group
and the time that they're taught that
they count includes the time of walking
from the other prior class to that class
and so they played with the numbers
and the fact was the students didn't get
what they were supposed to get and it
was a decision made largely apparently
on budget reasons in the case I saw
and we've got to look at that question
of is special ed something that we
should fund from the state or at least
assessed rather than say it's a local
school decision
soup
did that education in general
you can't remember that special
education is a different ball game than
what's going on in the classroom and the
the social emotional behavioral issues
in a classroom are not necessarily that
of special education and you have
several categories there dealing with
mental health you have other health
impaired which has exploded a little bit
uh however
the special education
I I'd like to congratulate special ed
teachers
um the the the the way they're being put
into these situations and they're having
to deal with and caseloads are
increasing
um difficulty of handling some of these
situations is beyond what I ever saw in
schools and and so I don't and and I
don't think we're side loading these
kids you were trying to mainstream those
especially with disabilities in the
classroom and and that's where we're
coming up with the Paris and all uh so I
I think we've gone by that hurdle I
think the issue we have is we got to get
back to this bill itself there's several
bills what is a comprehensive mental
health program where to smell how are we
going to support mental health in the
classroom how are we going to prepare
teachers to do that and and what are
those be the support services for the
teacher when you have to get
intervention beyond what the teachers
prepared and trained to provide
but I know that the the good teachers
I've always seen
they treat their classes almost like a
family and they put money in the bank in
other words they put all that invested
time in the bank and when they have to
pull it out with a kid there's there's
the kids willing to work with that
teacher and it becomes a situation
that's a pretty positive situation so a
lot of it I think comes from you know
those professional teachers and where'd
they get that lot was on the job
training but there's also I don't I
don't know what's going on the on the
higher education level now whether we're
getting into things besides Knowledge
and Skills but we're also getting into
the area with the pedagogy the the
ability to and the methods necessary to
work in today's education environment
I'd like to ask those questions I I
think we can we I think we can fix
things properly here it can be done uh
it's just going to take we need to spend
a couple of months here whittling and
drilling down and unpacking this whole
thing and and trying to get all that's
proper and it's going to support and be
put into Statute in the right places
and that's about what we can do as a
legislature it's the rest is on
incumbent upon the school districts and
I believe leadership in those buildings
yeah Alicia
I want to go back to what I learned
SEL trainings and conferences and stuff
um about the importance of School parent
and community and the question is what
can what can we do
to
try to form those bonds that have been
broken or that don't seem to exist in a
lot of places and there have been
communities in this state who worked
hard to get parent-teacher bonds and
they had extremely successful SEL
programs and the number of incidences in
the school decreased dramatically
you know behavioral instances Etc and so
we've seen in the state schools that
have been effective
the question is what can we do
to encourage that across the state and
try to get those
um
programs or whatever we have
schools who are very welcoming to
parents in schools that are not at all
welcoming to parents they don't even
want parents in the buildings and how do
we fix that how do we rebuild those
bridges like some of the districts have
done because I think that's what's going
to make a difference it's not a just
school that's siloing again just school
but how do we get out of the silo into
the community
you know what the schools that are doing
it a good job
what their best practices are what's
their percentage of the parents
attending the Parent-Teacher conferences
um for one uh what are there any parent
advisory councils within that school we
used to have them where I was and and we
listened
um
there's a lot of different things which
I think you can count as best practice
uh I I think a school that's locking
parents out I don't think that's what
the teachers really want
but some yes I don't agree that schools
are locking parents out I uh when you do
any kind of survey across the state
people like their Public Schools they
like their Community Schools if they
have kids in school they like the
schools they like the teachers okay it's
it's National political propaganda that
kind of stirs the pot with a lot of
things and also bringing up one case
scenarios whenever you have an
institution whether it's a hospital or a
school any institution where you're
dealing with the public you're always
going to get some people who are just
not satisfied with what's happening
maybe have some issues of their own or
some baggage about schools and their
their um they'll say you know they're
they're locking me out when in fact we
don't know at the at the bottom level
what the actual details are I think
Schools public schools that I have
worked with that I now represent that I
have represented
bend over backwards to work with parents
and and you're going to get one or two
parents that just it doesn't matter
that's that's not good enough and so
um I think we have to stop looking at
the
at the one outs the outliers and look at
the vast majority of what's Happening
if you want to end I would just say it
is all about leadership
and it's the leadership that sets a tone
and makes the demands
it was just like I told them to the
standards I I agree with you and a
hundred percent just yesterday across
the hallway the investigator
for Department of Education was
testifying on The subpoena powers that
the the department was looking for which
you know I will comment on that bill but
the
what month do you think that the
investigators notified more by parents
than any other month in the school year
we're in it right now
the school year is over now the parents
going to complain
and so the school that has the the the
the uh good best practices and openness
I bet you that I I go to that
investigator and say okay what are the
schools you're getting the stuff from
all the time or are are getting it from
verse which ones aren't you getting it
from the ones you're not getting it from
are the ones which are open and working
with parents
so so it's it's it comes down where
representative just said it's leadership
in that building setting the tone and
it's also the school board as well
working cooperatively together and it's
unfortunately apparently it must not be
happening everywhere
yep
just wondering when did you have lunch
already
12 30 please not speaking okay I'm done
I'm done okay so what we'll do is we'll
come back and we'll get this thing going
in September and the list that Mill has
right here we'll do some of that
following up and bring that information
back and we'll we'll take this thing
further and hopefully come to a positive
end for these three bills
foreign
anything else just just a final question
oh we had a handout on House Bill 1236
the oversight committee
um and I'm just questioning whether
anybody knows there's no public hearings
on these standards north of Concord
are they just not communicating with
someone
were requested by the districts
are Concord okay that tells you are you
going to request one
because I'd go to because I've been
waiting to go to one of these and
they're all down in the south
but I think
Poe sound like they wouldn't do it until
they have something
yeah
this is not the this is not the
department I'm sorry this is a state
it is Fred bramonte yes yes
it's a contract and service yeah
okay we're done we're adjourned for
today